[Música]
y
cuando se cumplen 100 días de ofensiva
rusa en ucrania las autoridades de
severo de nietos informaron que han
retomado el 20 por ciento de la ciudad a
su vez la unión europea aprobó el sexto
paquete de sanciones contra moscú y el
presidente vladimir putin aseguró que no
atacar a los puertos ucranianos que sean
desminados para el paso de cereales
bloqueado desde hace semanas
el movimiento ni una menos nacido en
argentina en 2015 cumplió siete años y
cientos de mujeres salieron a las calles
de buenos aires para exigir el fin de
los feminicidios la violencia machista y
la impunidad las mujeres reiteraron su
petición de una reforma judicial con
perspectiva de género
turquía cambio de nombre y de ahora en
adelante se llamará turquía en todos los
idiomas el gobierno de recep tayip
erdogán tomó la decisión para
reivindicar los valores culturales del
país tenemos recortes desde estambul
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
damos inicio en ucrania donde se cumplen
100 días desde el inicio de la invasión
rusa pese a que las fuerzas del kremlin
continúan su ofensiva en severo don jets
el ejército ucraniano informó que retomó
el control del 20 por ciento del
territorio perdido en esa ciudad
naciones unidas estima que más de 4.000
personas han perdido la vida y otras 5
mil han resultado heridas a causa de los
enfrentamientos
escuché muchas veces que severo don y es
que estaba ocupada que el ejército ruso
la tomó por completo quiero decirles que
no no fue tomada por completo antes la
situación era difícil el porcentaje era
de alrededor del 70 por ciento ahora los
hemos hecho retroceder en
aproximadamente un 20 por ciento a
continuación veremos un recuento de lo
que ha sido el conflicto que inició el
24 de febrero el presidente volodymyr
selenski informó que hasta el momento
rusia controla alrededor del 20 por
ciento del territorio ucraniano pero
resaltó que confía en que su país
logrará la victoria además de los
muertos y heridos esta guerra ha dejado
7 millones de refugiados y 8 millones de
desplazados internos casi 260 mil
deportaciones forzosas hacia rusia y al
menos 13.000 casos en estudio por
posibles crímenes de guerra
entre voces alarmistas y otras más
optimistas el 24 de febrero se cumplió
el peor de los pronósticos en europa
rusia decidió invadir ucrania bajo el
pretexto de desclasificar el país y
proteger a los ruso parlantes como un
primate tomado la decisión de lanzar una
operación militar sus abuelos y
bisabuelos solo lucharon defendiendo
nuestra patria para que los neonazis de
hoy se hicieran con el poder de ucrania
los rusos entraron a la nación vecina
por distintos frentes por el norte
noreste desde el donbass y por el sur
desde crimea en manos rusas desde su
ocupación en 2014 junto al pánico entre
los ucranianos y las pérdidas de vidas
humanas las sanciones de occidente no
tardaron en llegar wii a risoul conchi
estamos decididos a imponer costes
masivos a rusia costes que la aislarán
aún más del sistema financiero
internacional y en nuestras economías
las primeras conversaciones entre las
delegaciones rusas y ucranianas para
negociar el 28 de febrero no evitaron a
la avanzada rusa como una llamada de
auxilio del presidente ucraniano
demuestren que están con nosotros
demuestren que no nos dejarán demuestren
quiénes son verdaderamente europeos
entonces la vida vencerá a la muerte y
la luz a la oscuridad
con la caída de gerson el 3 de marzo la
primera derrota ucraniana el sufrimiento
solo acababa de empezar las mayores
víctimas hasta el momento los civiles
espero que mi esposa haya muerto rápido
de fast hope is this moment my wife's
pero que en este momento mi esposa está
en el cielo el que todo haya sido
perfecto en su vida en his life
tras otros bombardeos contra civiles
como el del teatro de mariupol uno de
los puntos de inflexión de la guerra se
vivió a principios de abril tras
descubrir decenas de cadáveres en lucha
tirados en las calles a maniatados algo
por lo que la comunidad internacional
empezó a hablar de genocidio
de la verdad del asunto usted vio lo que
pasó en lucha putin es un criminal de
guerra
con ayudas multimillonarias
ucrania consiguió hacer retroceder a los
rusos dejar que la segunda ciudad del
país a mediados de mayo pero no lograron
salvar mariupol que cayó en manos rusas
el 21 de mayo
como sostuvimos diferente
actualmente la avanzada rusa se
concentra en el este y en el horizonte
el fin de la guerra es muy incierto con
una multitudinaria protesta el colectivo
ni una menos conmemora los siete años
desde su fundación en argentina cientos
de mujeres marcharon en buenos aires
para exigir al gobierno que tome medidas
urgentes para enfrentar los feminicidios
la violencia machista y la falta de
igualdad de género con consignas como
vivas y libres nos queremos las mujeres
volvieron a pedir una reforma judicial
con perspectiva de género
previamente conversamos con victoria
freire socióloga y activista del
colectivo ni una menos que nos contó
cuáles podrían destacarse como los
mayores logros del movimiento tras siete
años de activismo
sin lugar a dudas el principal logro del
movimiento ni una menos tiene que ver
con haber generado un antes y un después
en la una pública respecto del debate y
la mirada de la violencia de género y un
movimiento un proceso de movilización
inmenso que conquistó la ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo la
ley del tipo laboral travesti tran logró
incorporar también a la legislación
sobre violencia de género aquella
violencia no suficientemente
visibilizada como la violencia política
en la violencia mediática
hemos logrado en este tiempo también
avanzar en la paridad en la
representación
política en las listas
de construcción electoral
hemos desarrollado creo son un proceso
que tiene su expresión en términos
legislativos con términos
institucionales
con la construcción de un ministerio
nacional de género mujeres y
diversidades por primera vez en la
historia pero también un proceso social
por abajo de organización de
construcción colectiva y de
acompañamiento ante situaciones de
violencia de género que siguen
sucediendo en nuestro país que siguen
encontrándose con muchísimos obstáculos
y con desigualdades estructurales que
están absolutamente presentes
este viernes cuba registró fuertes
lluvias provocadas por la tormenta
tropical álex formada por los restos del
huracán agatha pnv el temporal ha dejado
al menos un desaparecido cientos de
evacuados y daños en distintas
infraestructuras de la isla alva santana
nos amplía
inundaciones ríos desbordados y ya está
desaparecidos este es el panorama en el
occidente y el centro de cuba tras más
de 28 horas de lluvias ininterrumpidas
provocadas por la tormenta tropical alex
para esta intensidad ha sido mucha mucha
la intensidad de la lluvia no entra
gante que aguantes no se puede ver la
lluvia ha pasado de arriba ni para abajo
la uader a la cintura
y vivir como estamos viviendo con el
agua por las rodillas los cubanos han
estado intentando empujar autos y
autobuses atascados en las calles de la
capital la habana después de que el
fenómeno acumularse hasta 300 mililitros
de agua por metro cuadrado en algunas
zonas varias regiones del país están
incomunicadas y cientos de personas han
tenido que ser evacuadas
bueno la televisión había dicho de que
iba a llegar a hundan
pero no
el gobierno de miguel díaz canel ella
avisó que toda la isla está en alerta
máxima hasta próximo aviso por la
tormenta alex formada por los restos del
huracán agatha que había pasado en los
días anteriores por méxico dejando
muertos y desaparecidos desde el centro
nacional de huracanes de estados unidos
se espera que las lluvias continúen en
la isla a esta entrada la noche de este
viernes y se espera que sigan después en
florida y las islas bahamas
turquía cambió de nombre ahora del país
se llamará turquía en todos los idiomas
según le informó el gobierno de recep
tayip erdogán a naciones unidas el
organismo afirmó que el cambio de
nombres se realizará de inmediato desde
estambul adriana rocha corresponsal de
france 24 nos explica por qué se tomó
esta decisión turquía ya no existe a
partir de hoy mismo este viernes turquía
pasa a llamarse turquía que es lo mismo
que turquía pero en vez de un idioma en
extranjero será en turco así lo ha
confirmado naciones unidas- esta pasada
madrugada cuando ha confirmado que ha
recibido la carta del ministerio de
exteriores turco pidiendo precisamente
que se cambió el nombre oficial
internacional de erc iu en inglés y en
francés o turquía en español y sólo en
turco turquía
este movimiento lleva tratándose en
turquía desde el pasado desde el pasado
diciembre cuando el presidente turco
recep tayyp erdogán explicó que empezaba
a turquía esta iniciativa y viene sobre
todo por un gran motivo y es que en
inglés cherquis significa pavo que es lo
que comen los estadounidenses cuando
celebran uno de los días más populares
en su país que es el día de acción de
gracias además a erc iu en inglés
significa algo así como estúpido o tonto
una persona que no tiene mucho interés
en lo que hace ya hago turquía que se
quedó de distancia completamente en el
gobierno turco asegura que este cambio
es para intentar darle poder a los
turcos para poder que deciden ellos
mismos cómo quieren que su país sea
llamado internacionalmente sin embargo
pasará lo que les pasa a muchos otros
países que han cambiado el nombre hace
poco como la república checa- en 2016 o
holanda en 2020 a partir de entonces
holanda pasó a llamarse solamente países
bajos y la república checa- chequia sin
embargo internacionalmente se sigue
amando igual a estos países turquía
quiere hacer el mismo camino veremos en
el futuro los ciudadanos del mundo pasan
a llamarle de turquía turquía turquía o
en otros idiomas a solamente turquía
vamos hasta malí para hablar de la misma
una de las misiones de mantenimiento de
la paz calificada entre las más
mortíferas la misma se estableció en
abril de 2013 para estabilizar malí
después de que organizaciones
extremistas se hicieran con gran parte
del país ahora una copia exclusiva de un
informe inédito visto por france24
detalla una situación crítica en esta
nación de áfrica occidental esto
mientras dos miembros de las fuerzas de
paz
o no fueron asesinados este viernes
a la salida de francia de malí
beneficiará a las fuerzas hija vistas
del país según un informe exclusivo
conocido por france 24 el personal de la
operación de mantenimiento de la paz de
la onu minustah pide más personal de una
renovación de su misión por un año
mientras las autoridades malienses
intentan obstruir su trabajo hay son las
donde por ejemplo la zona de exclusión
aérea que impidió a la misma volar con
sus aviones se describe en el informe
con todo detalle una obstrucción de la
investigación que la misma quería llevar
a cabo en moura para averiguar lo
sucedido allí así como en otras regiones
del centro de mali
houston de allí el informe también
destaca el alcance de la minustah en el
país que está desplegada en regiones
peligrosas como go tombuctú y wells a
donde dos miembros de las fuerzas de paz
fueron asesinados el viernes los grupos
extremistas están intensificando sus
ataques en todo el país esta mañana con
el estado maliense controlador el 15% de
su territorio el 10% del norte y el 21%
del centro son cifras muy alarmantes amo
el informe es el segundo que se publica
este año después de que el primer
balance con un aumento de las
violaciones de las leyes internacionales
de derechos humanos con más de 12 mil
soldados desplegados en mali la misma es
la misión de la onu más peligrosa en el
mundo
en reino unido- en los miembros de la
familia real se reunieron el viernes en
la iglesia de sant paul para participar
de la ceremonia de acción de gracias' en
el marco de las celebraciones por el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel 2ª
una cita a la que la monarca no pudo
asistir debido a molestias de salud el
palacio de bukingham informó que la
reina no asistirá al hipódromo el sábado
para presenciar la carrera epson derbi
zumba ceremonia y fiesta la multitud se
reunió en las afueras de la catedral de
sampol el viernes para celebrar el
jubileo de platino de la reina isabel
segunda que cumple el récord de 70 años
en el trono la monarca de 96 años no
participó de servicio por problemas de
movilidad pero siguió el acto a través
de la televisión desde el castillo de
windsor bendita sea necesita descansar
ayer fue un gran día sin embargo la
familia de isabel segunda encabezada por
su hijo y heredero el príncipe carlos
estuvieron en representación de la
monarca en su primera aparición pública
en gran bretaña desde hace dos años
harry y megan fueron recibidos entre
aplausos y también abucheos
me encantan megan y jarro y creo que son
una pareja brillante se aman eso es lo
principal y la verdad es que me
sorprendió que la mayoría de la gente
abucheara no entiendo por qué
bueno siento decir que no soy fan de
harry y megan creo que son muy muy muy
respetuosos con la reina amo la reina y
creo que deberían ser más solidarios con
ella pero en un reflejo público de la
creciente presión sobre su liderazgo el
primer ministro boris johnson fue
recibido con un coro unánime de rechazo
la comitiva tomó asiento entre los dos
mil fieles y comenzó la misa
[Música]
su majestad lamentamos que no esté aquí
con nosotros esta mañana pero nos
alegramos de que siga en el cargo y nos
alegramos de que aún haya más por venir
así que gracias por seguir adelante
a pesar de que las celebraciones
continuarán durante todo el fin de
semana el palacio de buckingham ha
confirmado que la reina también se
perderá la carrera de caballos del derby
de epsom así como un concierto de música
pop en su honor el sábado
así finalizamos esta emisión de noticias
gracias por su sintonía volvemos en
breve
[Música]